hi there Steve Kaufman I hope the sound
is louder there were some complaints
about the sound here I want to talk
today about learning German this is part
of the series that I've been doing where
I speak in a language other than English
and then follow that up with a
discussion about that learning that
language I have been doing that the last
few weeks and of course because I
haven't been speaking much Spanish
German and now I'm going to do Italian
next week therefore I wanted to refresh
my knowledge of those languages before
doing a video and so I spent three four
days or so prior to the video on link
studying that language I found podcast I
was reading in the language I had
discussions with some of our link tutors
in the language and so forth one of the
interesting things is that the comments
that I've received from people who saw
those videos or who spoke to me our
tutors it was that I had improved in
those languages even though I hadn't
spoken them much this is a very
interesting point because the fact that
I've been working hard on other
languages like Russian Czech Romanian
and so forth actually improves my
ability to notice things in foreign
languages it improves my language
learning fitness and therefore with a
little bit of effort i refresh my
recently neglected languages and bring
them back to a level which is often
higher than it was before I'm noticing
this now in my Italian that I in fact
understand Italian better when it listen
to audio or these podcasts that I find
on the net about history or politics I
understand them better than I did before
so just a little note for those of you
who sometimes are afraid to leave one
language for six months in order to
study another yeah you'll slip a bit but
eventually you'll become a better
language learner
okay now insofar as German my parents
were born in the austro-hungarian Empire
into a german-speaking Jewish
community in Moravia which subsequently
became part of Czechoslovakia and so
therefore they went to Czech school and
they spoke both German and Czech in 39
they escaped to Sweden where I was born
in 1945 and at the age of 5 we moved
when I was five we moved to Canada I
have no recollection of transitioning
from Swedish to English at home we
always my brother and I spoke English
with my parents they told us we're in
Canada now you will speak English
and we my brother and I my parents spoke
German to each other we resented German
we resented hearing it
we resented everything having to do with
Europe because my parents would always
say that Canadians were lazy Canada had
no culture and so forth and everything
European was good and they wanted us to
be make friends with the children of
their European friends and those were
the last people we wanted to make
friends with so there was this
resistance to German now things changed
when I was 19 after two years at McGill
University and I was working in a summer
job on construction and then I was laid
off and I thought you know what I think
I'll go off to Europe so I went down to
the Port of Montreal and spent three
days trying to see the captains of
different ships in the port on the third
day I found a captain of a German ship
who had lost a sailor in Quebec City and
said yeah you can work your way across
with us so for ten days I was on this
small [ __ ] steamer which was just up
and down off across the Atlantic I was
hammering away at rust and scraping and
painting uh and that was the first time
that it actually meant something to me
to try and say something in German and I
had my little German book with the you
know the declensions of the mounds and
the pronouns and it was just horrendous
but at least then German became
meaningful to me briefly and then I
hitchhiked around Europe including in
Germany I can remember even
on a usually state in youth hostels I
arrived in I think it was burbling in
and it was pouring with rain after 11
o'clock at night and I went to their
local jail and asked if I could stay
there and they accommodated me very
comfortable jail um
and then I also worked two weeks on
construction in Vienna where I spoke
some German although most of the other
workers were Turks and that was it and
then I studied for three years in France
did nothing with German until 1987 when
I was between jobs you know I was after
my 3 years in France I joined the
Canadian Diplomatic Service was sent to
Hong Kong to learn Mandarin Chinese
subsequently went to Japan then I left
the embassy went to work for a major
Canadian forest products exporting
company and so that's through the 70s
and then in 1987 I left I was between
jobs and I decided to learn German I'm
not quite sure why so I went to all of
the secondhand bookstores in Vancouver
and I found lots of books textbooks that
other people had used you know things
like this and they're full of texts more
or less boring texts and vocabulary
which is what I needed they also have
you boolean drills and stuff which I
have always resisted doing in language
learning I don't like them I if anything
all I do with them is I look up the
answers so I can see some concentrated
examples of whatever pattern they're
trying to test you on but I feel it's
not that useful to to try and scratch
your brain to answer these questions
at any rate I didn't bring them all down
I showed more of them in my German
language video there were lots of them
and of course interesting about German
history culture and so forth and of
course even though I initially was kind
of resisting German the more you get
into a language the more you find it
interesting and this is another I think
important point people say I'm not that
interested in whatever get into it start
into it you may find that as they say in
French La Petite via on mahjong in other
words the appetite grows with the eating
and so then you get more and more into
it you'll find it in
thing as soon as possible I tried to get
away from these sorry lab textbooks one
very good source was a series of audio
cassettes of ordinary people talking and
I listened to those interviews many many
times I can remember them one was an
interview with a locomotive engineer who
had you know driven the train when the
Queen of England was on the train and
another guy was talking about how
farmers in Bavaria can't find wives
because they smell a whole bunch of
stuff but real people and I've always
felt that listening to real people
speaking if it's transcribed and you get
a chance to I didn't have transcripts
but ideally transcripts is an ideal way
to learn and that's why when we set up
link I began and initially they only
offered English and I started
interviewing lots of people and creating
content on link with transcripts because
I felt that if you give people the
chance to feel that they're
eavesdropping on a genuine conversation
that that's very effective learning
material so that was more or less what I
did with German stayed with it then it
so happened that I set up my own company
in the trade of wood products and we
were in the early 90s selling wood to
Germany so I was now travelling to
Germany and so then I tried even harder
to learn German bought books read and of
course spoke with people and gradually
my German improved and I also began to
appreciate German culture more and you
know just to digress in my previous
videos about Russian or Spanish you know
I explained or French some of the
attractiveness of those cultures and
German culture is often seen as you know
less fun than let's say Italian or
Spanish you know the Sun the music and
so forth but you have to appreciate
cultures for what they are and I think
the thing about German culture is a
sense of comfort solid comfort you stay
in a German or
tell I mean the doors closed solidly the
windows are solid and and so German
culture to me is is less about you know
dancing and singing it's more about you
know it's like you're sitting there
reading a book or one of these very
serious German newspapers and Bach is
playing in the background and and it's
raining outside and but there's that's
comfortable too
you know I like that and I like the
there their pubs with the wonderful
wooden paneling and and and so you kind
of learn to appreciate each culture for
what it is and of course the the towns
in Germany especially the smaller towns
are absolutely beautiful and Germany
into historically you know shallow man
who's you know revered in France was in
fact the German a franc Germans have had
a major imprint on European history
Martin Luther of course the 30 Years War
by the way there's an excellent audio
book on the 30 Years War which I've
listened to many times ah and of course
in the more recent past there's been you
know with two world wars where we won't
go into that subject but today in
Germany and I can say this as someone of
a Jewish background that no country has
addressed you know their own recent
history the way the Germans have it's
amazing it's amazing to walk around
Hamburg and see plaques with the names
of Jewish people who used to live in
that house and so I mean as far as I'm
concerned you know as my uncle once said
the Germans of that generation of the
generation of the war he doesn't want to
have anything to do with but Germans of
subsequent generation absolutely no
problem at all and in fact the Germans I
find are very friendly I recently drove
through Germany people and you did to
the you know the superficial contact
that I have with them in hotels or gas
stations whatever super friendly and
there's a hundred million German
speakers in Europe so it's an extremely
important language so I think there's so
many positive reasons now some people
say they like German rock music I don't
do rock music hard rock all
stuff right whatever I don't know you
know what it is I have no interest but
in fact I'm a bit old-fashioned I like
good you know so I like listening to
audiobooks of good I love his language
and you can get the texts on the
internet and so I can import them in the
link and study them you know what else I
like reading about history so you know
for something like this for example and
unfortunately many of these books you
know they're they're are you probably
see it there's a lot of words that I
don't know I would prefer to read these
on link so I could look them up and
they're in the words but when you're
down to not too many words that you
don't know then it's not that big a
chore to read without knowing all the
words I'm trying to think of what else I
wanted to say about German yeah I mean
it's an extremely important language I
think a lot of people in Eastern Europe
now are because of the economic might of
Germany Germany is German in Eastern
Europe in Russia is becoming the next
important language after English and
it's it's a fascinating in terms of its
literature in terms of history in terms
of philosophy it is a fascinating
culture I am NOT into science or
medicine but even their course German
has in the past been very important I
wanted to finish off with with one other
point that has come up and that's this
issue of talent you know some people say
to me oh you have a talent for languages
or I have like talking about themselves
I have no talent for languages
I don't think talent is all that
important granted you may sit there and
say well Steve you know your parents
spoke German to each other you heard
German at home you spoke Swedish for the
first five years of your life therefore
you can learn other languages more
easily I can't do that say some people
but then I look around and I see all of
the wonderful polyglots that I know in
our polyglot community on the Internet
if I think of Luca who grew up
unilingual Italian Richard simcha grew
up unilingual English if I think of all
the Swedes that I know or the Dutchman
who are Germans who are so fluent in
English
I it's not about Talent some people may
be better than others in terms of their
ability to imitate accent but
overwhelmingly it's your motivation your
interest in the language your sense that
you will achieve your goal that you're
willing to stay with it spend the time
and of course to develop that ability to
notice and that's so important and
that's why I made reference at the
beginning of my talk about how taking a
break from German Spanish Italian
actually improved my ability to notice
what's going on in German Spanish in
Italian and that's why for example when
I read away from Linc I will always
underline words and phrases and of
course in link that those of you aren't
familiar with Linc you save words and
phrases which we call creating links
well I create them by the tens of
thousand the more you can create those
links and then they reappear highlighted
in yellow that draws your attention to
words to phrases to patterns and you
have to do that in order to help the
brain notice otherwise we notice some
things but we don't notice other things
and the more things we can notice that
the brain has already grown accustomed
to noticing the more new things we can
notice so to finish off then I think
rather I would like to say rather than
focusing on talent worrying about
whether you have talent or not focusing
focus on developing the ability to
notice so there you have it again I ran
over my ten minutes but some complained
that my videos were too long and others
said they didn't mind